got ever
no water
, there's no question that Walter is
absolutely gorgeous stunning the thing
is that he's [ __ ] totally insane like
right now for example Walter has decided
that these white bedsheets are all his
and if anybody gets too close to them
even his own father it's gonna be
trouble
that's my baby it's not just sheets it's
food it's it's not always like that just
a lot of the time what do you think Bern
Versace Baron going to Indianapolis
I can't Tom Waits
sure
gonna be a movie good job haha
do we get any good one poor man how much
does the most money you've ever got some
new special that's a couple grand for
you yeah you get a couple great mom
would save us personally no big man [ __ ]
what's the most paparazzi money you got
for one picture I can't talk about that
and yeah good game hey thank you we go
in the schmuck line going to the nap
Oh
I'm right in the middle of the street
what I just notarized was my criminal
history disorderly conduct
drunk driving for drunk driving violated
my probation driving without a license
siege ative from justice public
urination possession of ecstasy of
marijuana
open container battery and two counts of
trespassing possession ever cocaine
vandalism solvent weapon what weapon did
you assault solely with my microphone
steve-o is here with us mr. Bob and Tom
show 1070 the fan how many times really
did you hit the the dump button probably
five times it's a record I mean normally
once you're not comfortable people says
let's not a me socket socket no oh my
yeah we're gonna be halfway through the
Horde if you do it just right then you
can open it all the way up and you're in
the middle of floors and get P down an
elevator shaft yeah we saw that hosting
okay last night I heard it's the age of
the selfie for the first time and look
how happy I am in the photo I took at
that moment thank you so much for
watching these silly videos on this
second channel of mine subscribe to it
right here and it's the age of the
selfie and I'll see on the road you